una confesión televisada en directo john
bolton ex asesor de seguridad de donald
trump reconoció haber ayudado a
organizar golpes de estado en el
extranjero bolton dio la declaración en
el marco de una entrevista en 100 en
este martes cuando el periodista jake
paper le preguntaba por el asalto al
capitolio del 6 de enero de 2020 en
snatch no es un ataque a nuestra
democracia es donald trump actuando en
su propio beneficio es algo que ocurrió
una sola vez en la vida
con todo el respeto no sé si estoy de
acuerdo con usted para ser justos no
tiene que ser brillante para intentar
dar un golpe de estado siguiente que no
estoy de acuerdo como alguien que ha
ayudado a planear golpes de estado no
aquí ya sabes en otros lugares requiere
mucho trabajo y eso no es lo que hizo
otro hombre
bolton no especificó cuántas veces en
cuántos países ni con qué colaboradores
organizó los golpes de estado en el
extranjero pero ante la contundencia y
la imprecisión de su confesión el
periodista le preguntó
y usted dijo que tenía experiencia
planeando golpes de estados que no voy a
entrar en detalles pero pero golpes de
estado con éxito en escribir sobre
venezuela en el libro finalmente no tuvo
éxito no es que tuviéramos tanto que ver
con él pero vi lo que implicó para una
oposición intentar derrocar un
presidente elegido ilegalmente y
fracasaron la idea de que donald trump
fuera la mitad de competente que la
oposición venezolana es ridícula
siento que hay cosas que no me está
contando
estoy seguro que las hay
el exfuncionario también ocupó altos
cargos en las administraciones
republicanas de reagan de bush padré y
de bush hijo habitual de foxnews también
es miembro de los think tank
neoconservadores más influyentes de eeuu
que defienden la línea más dura de la
política intervencionista y militarista
estadounidense sobre todo en américa
latina y medio oriente